we're down by four points we're on our
own three yard line we've got 30 seconds
left and no timeouts what happens when
nothing is done to stop climate change
well the Gulf Coast of Louisiana is a
pretty good example of it here every
hour about a football field of land is
lost to rising sea levels while the oil
and gas industry has been an economic
life-giver to this region it's also the
reason that life here may soon be
impossible welcome to Dulac a town in
the indigenous Houma nation Territory it
sits at 3 feet above sea level but with
a gulf set to rise by more than 4 feet
by the year 2100 all this will soon be
underwater he used to be further this
way but now it's all washed off you know
I pray the pollens and everything else
over there that was all ground here this
entire area used to be marshland which
helps slow down hurricanes but as gas
companies began to dig more and more
canals salty seawater started seeping in
killing the wetlands to date coastal
Louisiana has lost 1/4 of its land since
the 1930s are you at all concerned that
a Dulac will one day look like this oh
yeah when I was younger this used to be
our land the little canal would come
through never just the ditch and now we
can float a boat through it I might not
be here maybe 20-30 years in here now
the Gulf of Mexico is gonna be a new
left
I think this iris is this Cana just
finished up um a viruses we're just
growing the earth by digging up the oil
and the coal it makes its making it more
sick it's not just small towns that are
in danger this coastline is home to half
of the country's oil refineries 90% of
offshore energy production and the
nation's largest port and in the next 50
years most of what is not protected by
levees will be gone so what's happened
is you have a delta that has been
totally destroyed and so it's sinking
and it's sinking now at the same time
the sea is rising so when I was in my
20s Big Cat Island in eastern Barataria
Bay was a mile long and a half a mile
wild in 1998 when I took this picture
this was about 150 yards wide twitted
yards long and this is what it looked
like six years later certainly there are
a lot of people here who work for the
oil and gas industry but pretty soon all
that infrastructure will be destroyed by
hurricane storm surge and nothing is
being done really significantly by the
oil and gas industry to prevent this
from happening but there is a plan to
protect against land loss by restoring
the wetlands it's called the coastal
master plan but so far it only has a
fraction of the more than 90 billion
dollars it needs to work the plan would
take this and turn it back into this so
this area here shell Bank Bayou is one
of the last examples of a Tupelo Cypress
Swamp all of these trees are not
reproducing
so it's an example of what this land
used to look like many years ago Katya
and Eric are part of gulf south rising
an initiative of climate justice
activists who work with frontline
communities here those most affected by
climate change so here we're leaving
shell bank by when going out onto Lake
Maurepas which is a brackish water lake
and this is an area where you can really
see the saltwater intrusion you'll start
to see a lot of the bald cypress trees
that are under the salt water have been
eaten away by the salt water Eric what
about you how does it feel to be out
here that sentence me and it makes makes
you realize that like we are the last
generation that will see this like my
children would never get to see half of
this eric introduced us to his cousin
Sean they both live in Slidell a
front-line community that completely
flooded out during Hurricane Katrina and
is also at risk of soon disappearing but
you lived in this area for how long my
whole life 27 years but this is my
grandmother's house right over here how
tall is that now eight feet they're
going up eight feet and before just on
the ground yeah before I was on the
ground house raising costs tens of
thousands of dollars which many
residents have to pay out-of-pocket if
they're not lucky enough to get a state
grant I think we're looking at mass
relocation especially of unique
communities long-standing Creole
communities Native American communities
and we're looking at mass relocation for
sure Colet and gulf south rising are
fighting for climate justice and what
often feels like a losing battle
but for many communities at risk it's
the only chance they've got we cannot
sustain extracting oil and gas we just
can't sustain it it's sinking the land
in South Louisiana it's caught it's
accelerating climate change we can't
keep doing it I think the people who are
being impacted have great ideas maybe
it's just time for us to listen